[Music] It
's a duel
[Music] If
we win, you'll
recognize Thread as my fiancée.
If we lose, you can do whatever you want. Didn't you understand what I was saying?
We
'll fight according to the rules you set.  I'm telling you, you're an
adult and should take responsibility for what you decide.
[Music] Is your
opinion correct?Although it was a
coincidence, that was the
aircraft that defeated our company's Diranza.We are considering its use for a while now.  What do you think?
What do you mean? In
recent years, the market
share of other companies' mobile suits has
been increasing. I wonder if that aircraft can be the catalyst for a recovery in business performance. I
think the duel at the school will be useful as a demonstration test for aerials.
[Music] Will you
provide me with the technical information? Of course. I'm
against it. People who break the conjugate guess what. I'm against it. How about making an
announcement to a lot of people? I won. If I lose,
Aerial will be discarded. You too will be
expelled from school.  I'll
definitely win